so you've already had your lunch and
your hours away from dinner and you
steal yourself in towards that classic 3
p.m. crash stop don't head in to the
staff room to eat that crusty
grocery-store cake from last week's
retirement party don't stand in front of
a vending machine trying to cite which
sad snack you're gonna try to choke down
don't be that person the key to
successful mid-day snacking is planning
ahead to have the best snacks on hand
they're gonna keep you energized and are
gonna curb your appetite so that you
don't plow through a big bag of chips
right in front on the fridge before
dinner take a peek at my top 3 power
snack they'll help boost you out of that
3 p.m. energy slump my first snack is a
half a cup of clean fat-free Greek
yogurt top with half a cup of
raspberries and a half an ounce of
crushed almonds the most satisfying
snacks are those with the hunger
crushing combination of protein fiber
and good for you healthy fats like
almonds for example I also like to keep
my snacks under 200 calories because
that really keeps me on track for the
rest of the day so I don't overdo it
before dinner
my second snack is to cook three
tablespoons of steel-cut oats with about
3/4 of a cup of boiling water then I
added about a half a tablespoon of
almond butter and top with two
tablespoons of fresh blueberries and
finally my third snack is a little chia
pudding I've got 3 tablespoons of chia
seeds mix with about 3/4 of a cup of
almond milk and I let that sit in the
fridge overnight then the next day I top
it off with a little bit of chopped
fresh fig so there you have it three
fantastic snack combinations that help
get you to the dinner time finish line
without any hangry meltdowns
what are your go-to midday satisfying
snacks upload yours and share them with
me using this hashtag thanks so much for
joining us at Abbey's kitchen be sure to
subscribe to my channel leave me a
comment below and check back for some
more great videos to nabis kitchen
you